ok ça marche
bonjour et bienvenue pour c'est ma force
c'est en direct de monterrosa en italie
et en particulier je vais coacher noms
venus gets par tony parker mais oh je
suis à côté de la cave anne de ni
affirmatif
voilà donc j'aimerais faire une vidéo
aujourd'hui pour vous parler des
commentaires de fêtes de 12,9 vidéo la
première c'est celle sur youtube
tourisme ya plus un an avec monsieur
fille et la deuxième c'est celle sur la
morale désir entre parenthèses et pour
nous qui est sorti il ya deux jours par
rapport à la vidéo que je retente film
et ils vont le temps que je monte tout
ça
tel que je rentre chez moi je suis un
peu mieux nulle part c'est pas ce soir
que je vais monter je prends un
ordinateur mais là j'aimerais revenir un
peu sur les commentaires de ces vidéos
parce que ce sont deux vidéos qui parle
deux sujets hésiter vidéo lattes et
parle de sujets assez incitatives les
sujets ou publics en louisiane en ou va
ressurgir on va voir beaucoup de
beaucoup beaucoup de mauvais réflexes et
à chaque fois avancé vidéo j'ai vraiment
ouais j'ai fait mon maximum pour
préparer en gros ces vidéos pour essayer
d'amener un contexte dans lequel on
pourrait parler assez sereinement assez
calmement et de façon assez posé et
réfléchi et bienveillante et de tous ces
sujets vraiment difficiles et
malheureusement j'ai l'impression que
c'est un petit peu un échec
les commentaires que je ne vis pas c'est
pas tant qu'il est mauvais commentaires
je sais que les commentaires sous une
fraction très très très faible en fait
et non représentatif de l'ensemble des
personnes qui regardent des vidéos et
beaucoup de très bons retours de
beaucoup d'entre vous qui avait
accueilli qui sont pas forcément
d'accord avec l'idée par exemple du sivi
du la position cohérente extraits dont
j'ai parlé dans la vidéo sur la morale
désire savoir s'il faut c'est
parfaitement normal ne pas être d'accord
moi j'ai eu beaucoup de réserve mais ça
ça me dérange pas en les gens qui sont
pas d'accord ce que je trouve assez
normal c'est que revint en savoir si
mauvais réflexe débats dès qu'on parle
de morale c'est c'est connaître et
hooligans très voilà je vais m'exprimer
je vais dire ce que je pense
et histoire de déterminer mes
convictions et avec parfois un air un
peu condescendant avec 1 ère fois allumé
qui a même pas compris que attends je
vais t'expliquer voilà tu es tombé roja
et que parfois avec un air très
sarcastique du joueur allemand qui il
pense que les ias 16 ouvrages sa réserve
jouera tout ou alors le mec qui pensent
que les tuera désastre a fondu avec une
tendance à exagérer a poussé vraiment à
l'extrême certains arguments mais de
façon malveillante d'ailleurs vraiment
poussé à l'extrême dans un mauvais sens
non sens tournai henry en dérision
certains des arguments bref tous ces
mauvais réflexe que l'on attend dé voir
ont sélectionné le plus mauvais argument
du côté opposé pourquoi critiquer tout
le côté opposé
tous ces mauvais réflexe que l'on a
lorsque l'on débat malheureusement
penser suite à mes vidéos dans les
commentaires j'ai beaucoup plus ressenti
ce genre de mauvaise façon de débattre
apparaître que dans les autres vidéos
que j'ai fait à nombre de commentaires
et go également que ces vidéos plus de
commentaires que d'habitude et ça vient
aussi du fait qu on envie de réagir à ce
genre de trucs on a envie de donner trop
de votre opinion sauf que soit en fait
montre opinion dans notre intuition
moral est souvent très très instinctive
très très fort j'ai par la sélection
naturelle plein de biais de sophismes
plein de rationalisation là j'en vois
tous les épisodes que j'ai fait ou j'ai
parlé et reparlé retardé de toutes ces
notions et ça ça fait que
malheureusement ça invite pas du tout
aux débats ça va vite et pas du tout à
progresser moralement ça ça fait pas du
tout réfléchi arni la personne qui écrit
commentaires n'y a personne qui lira ce
commentaire suppression des trains
mauvaise foi semble se débattre
or malheureusement géants figurant sur
malheureusement ça serait bien que ça
soit pas une priorité mais
malheureusement je pense que c'est
devenu une priorité morale aujourd'hui
que de mieux débattre de façon honorable
que de discuter de morale
ces sujets que j'aurai avec l'argent
évité si je les trouvais pas du tout
important voyage europe continue à faire
des mathématiques
c'est votre travail au noir du mat et
puissant mais j 13 août à voir ces
moments de déprime l'an dernier les
commentaires mais malheureusement ces
sujets devraient elles sont des sujets
importants et il faut absolument qu'on
apprenne non pas à résoudre le moral ça
ce sera pour un second temps mes
premières moi je pense que c'est super
important d'abord de mieux parler de
morale de s'écouter simplement d'écouter
et de comprendre les points de vue des
uns et des autres de chercher à avoir
une vision cohérente de notre propre
intuition moral et chercher à trouver
des failles de nos intuitions morale à
comprendre pourquoi est ce que on a les
intuitions morales que l'on a est ce
qu'elle ne serait pas dû à des sophismes
à des biais cognitif et si vous
connaissez un petit peu
la lâche pas une vidéo issue connaissez
un peu de calme and kate un cerveau la
tronche en biais ou origine mental vous
savez notre intuition a énormément de
biais de soufisme de biais cognitif de
base des du statut pro d2 familiarité où
je pars faire une vidéo on a énormément
de biais et sa chance et bien c'est ça
me semble complètement déraisonnée juste
mal plus de penser que l'on détient déjà
la bonne morale
donc l'on puisse penser que la moelle
qu'on a d'aujourd'hui suffi 1 à white
comme on aujourd'hui ne suffit pas
aujourd'hui on a une mauvaise foi on
réfléchit pas assez la morale n'a pas
assez réfléchi avoir simplement n'ajuste
hérité la morale de notre environnement
et et de nos gènes et du coup on est
souvent faso n'est pas mal par notre
environnement puis sourit coup prison et
ses façades ont conduit à la morale que
l'on a mais cette morale n'est pas du
tout réseau n'est pas du tout à fait chi
malheureusement c'est important de
parler de morale voilà donc je fais
cette vidéo pour ainsi d'insister sur le
fait que bien parler de morale c'est
extrêmement important
mais c'est également extrêmement
difficile il faut qu'on se sent courage
mutuellement à chaque fois que quelqu'un
fait quelque chose de bien
non pas d'un point de vue moral mais
d'un point de vue débat à mourad
quelqu'un qui reconnaît ou qui défend
une opinion opposée à la sienne
j'aimerai vous voir ça souvent c'est un
truc moi je fais un truc que j'essaie de
faire quotidiennement clair que à chaque
fois que quelqu'un expriment un avis
avec lequel je suis d'accord c'est
l'occasion de changer de perspective
essaie de montrer en quoi l'autre à at
war et oui en fait c'est l'autre est
d'accord avec nous donc c'est vrai tout
pendant une façon de montrer en quoi on
a tort une façon plus générale le voir
personnellement à chaque fois que j'ai
une intuition morales que nous demander
est ce que c'est un boni notion morale à
avoir et la façon que j'ai trouvée de
faire c'est de faire ça c est ce que
bonds a plus plus est ce que bon mois +
+ aurait cette intuition moral et c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que je trouve le
concept de moi puissent plus assez assez
fascinant
donc c'est un truc un petit peu
introduit en parlant avec des amis j'ai
commencé à trouver ça très très utile et
ouais et je suis pas développé dans la
vidéo mes yeux c'est un concept que je
ressentais la cendre introduire du coup
dans cette vidéo qui concèdent deux mois
plus tôt que moi plus c'est juste moi
qui ai plus réfléchie le roi puisque
s'il ya vraiment réfléchi très très
longtemps finalement longtemps et il a
toute l'information du nombre de mois +
wii s'est informé un peu plus il a plus
réfléchi et déjà c'est de tendre vers
moi plus à chaque fois comme moi plus
longs mois déjà de temps donc si je
regarde moi plus que l'année dernière
enfin pas en noir du présent est un mois
plus de lois du mois de l'année dernière
parce qu'au cours de la dernière année
j'ai beaucoup réfléchi à toutes ces
questions et je me suis plus beaucoup en
forme et j'ai beaucoup appris sur pas
mal de sujets et du coup je suis un mois
+ du mois de l'année dernière je trouve
qu'au même mois de l'année dernière à
des points auxquels voilà il ne l'est
pas assez d'importance à ça donner trop
d'importance à d'autres choses
wen a été trop collé sur d'utilitarisme
typiquement aujourd'hui moi plus urgent
est un peu plus une période que moi
diamant voilà c'est ce genre de truc qui
fait que je pense qu'il ya un progrès
moral et si on accepte le fait qu' on
progresse moralement quand on réfléchit
à la morale suffisamment longtemps et
qu'on s'informe au tour de ces
qualifications en descendant d'enlever
nos biais cognitif
il semble qu'il ya vraiment une notion
de deux mois plus apparaître ici on
imagine quelqu'un qui laisser
indéfiniment on a vraiment une seconde
et moi plus puce qui émerge est d'une
certaine manière
ouais moi puisque c'est vraiment où la
seule entité pour je peux dire assez
clairement qu'elle est très largement
supérieur à moi même infiniment
supérieur mois en un certain sens où il
ne pourrait y avoir personne de
supérieur est selon moi j'ai parlé de
moi je sais que je vais faire un petit
360 devrait présenter un beau paysage
change un petit peu les idées c'est
quand même trop beau que à la montagne
les alpes c'est quand même trop four
on fait passer au dessus des 4000 en
europe alors je suis bien passé dès 4000
en amérique en asie et en afrique
normalement si pour elle de vin ou
après-demain tricycle habito est pas
très bonne foie de veau à la non
récurrents que après demain à priori à
la météo a de bonnes du coup vous
pourrez faire un sou mais les too much
pitt alors que la fois je suis pas très
sûrs d'eux parce qu'être des tweets mais
j'espère qu'on pourra le faire
quatre mille cinq cents à base de lait
fer le mont blanc mais bon voilà
mais comme l'esprit dans une autre vidéo
ci a été publiés normalement à l'homme
idée la météo n'est pas très bonnes pour
faire le mouvement vite fait trop chaud
y être au sud de pierres des bouts alors
non petit peu à la morale maintenant aux
choses sérieuses l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles c'est devenu vraiment
vraiment important en doctorat de morale
c'est juste que les technologies qu'on a
aujourd'hui sont beaucoup plus
puissantes que les technologies qu'on
avait dans le passé ou à l'époque des
grecs par exemple et que du coup d'essai
revenir n'a plus de pouvoir avec les
technologies qui mena on est capable
d'influencer directement
donc en plus de gens grâce aux
technologies que l'on a ou à cause des
technologies cma et comme dirait la
citation de spider man le grand pouvoir
implique de grandes responsabilités et
le plus grand de ces puissantes de ces
technologies
déjà aujourd'hui dire encore plus dans
le futur surtout si elle devient
surhumaine signa sur l'intelligence
artificielle qui a vraiment le pouvoir
de complètement bouleversé la manière
dont on vit de grandement améliorer la
qualité de vie de tous
donc compris et surtout même des
personnes on extrême pauvreté
moi en particulier personnellement le
truc qui me fait particulièrement
flipper c'est assez similaire de niveau
humain et il y aura une loi de niveau
humain avec très très très grande
probabilité selon beaucoup gens si on
fait une agrégation de la vie de bleu
des chercheurs du domaine avec 50 pour
l'été il y aura avant la fin du siècle
il n'ya de niveau humain moi j'ai même
peur qu'elle arrive avant parce que
quand on parle de sécurité on parle des
pires cas et dans le pire cas si on
écoute un peu les experts les experts
l'expert médian donne une probabilité de
10%
vous faites qui l'unît à deux niveaux
humain en 2025 donc ça fait flipper
c'est un gag du mont de marsan il faut
avoir résolu le problème de la morale à
ce moment là avant avant qu'il n'ya de
niveau humain c'est pour moi la
discussion la plus importante à avoir de
toute l'humanité aujourd'hui c'est le
futur de l'humanité dépend de la
discussion morales que l'on va voir dès
ce qu'on a à d aujourd'hui et qu'on va
continuer à voir dans les années à venir
et en particulier de notre acceptation
de kader espèce de consensus il faut
desservir qu'on se mette d'accord sur
une façon de programmer la mouradia face
à ça soulagera énormément tous les
chercheurs tous les experts du domaine
si on arrive à se mettre d'accord sur
une ligne à sur le moral a programmé ça
permettra de faire une force
enfin un lobby beaucoup plus qu'une plus
niveau beaucoup plus clair beaucoup plus
efficace auprès des gens qui développent
sesia auprès de google en concluant en
particulier et padar forcément parce que
finir google c'est les gens les plus est
inquiète souvent quand on lit les
articles de recherche aujourd'hui en
sécurité de google dit man donc faut pas
qu'on a tendance à avoir cette vision un
peu manichéenne là sinon c'est une
entreprise s ils sont méchants tout ça
mais en fait c'est eux qui ont lieu qui
sont les premiers à flipper de la
possibilité d'une ya deux niveaux humain
et qui font de la recherche sur le sujet
et sont moqués par des chercheurs
académiques
universitaire à ce sujet un peu le monde
à l'envers et secousse a vraiment bien
dommage
ouais ça vient du fait je pense que tout
simplement on n'a pas assez réfléchi aux
conséquences d'une ya deux niveaux du
mode d'une part et de la difficulté des
questions morales vraiment résoudre le
point de la morale c'est un point de
digne des plus grands talents de la
prochaine génération
la thématique de la prochaine génération
d'excideuil post-roll énormément
d'importance aux dangers de la morale
dédia et fait qu'elle soit soit pas
programmé c'est pas programmer ces
foutus de l'humanité je prends à 97 4 1
7% cette foutue d'humanité si si
personne ne pense à soi à cause d une
morale de les ja forte heureusement je
pense que ça sera pas le cas parce que
aujourd'hui l'industrie en particulier
google et surtout google et j'aimerais
que d'ailleurs facebook et compagnie
prenne plus engagement publiquement en
faveur d'une recherche sur la morale
désir mais google c'est un petit peu
positionné dans le ceo de google a écrit
le pdg de google a écrit sur le blog de
google un billet où il parle un peu d
importance tâche de faire des gars qui
sont bénéfiques pour l'humanité je parle
pas encore dit à deux niveaux humain et
de noir désir
quelques j'aimerais mais c'est déjà un
premier pas important j'aimerais que les
autres entreprises suivent
j'aimerais que les instituts de
recherches suivent et j'aimerais que les
pays s'engagent également à suivre ce
genre de directives
là ça me rassurerait beaucoup que le
comprennent tous plus conscience tu
donnais d'une ia programmés soit sans
valeur morale ou soit avec des valeurs
morales inadéquate par exemple unis à
l'utilitarisme sera catastrophique pour
risques pour l'humanité tête il faut
absolument bien passé c'est probable et
surtout faut surtout que ce prométhée
reprennent est extrêmement difficile
il y a énormément de défis à résoudre
donc j'essaie d'apporter ma pierre à
l'entrée des halles à contribution pour
ton de dire moi je
j'aurais aimé ne plus avoir à faire de
recharge
mais quand je me suis rendu compte du
problème de l'ia je me suis dit faut
absolument que je fasse tout son
possible pour que ça aille bien pour que
la morale désiré soit programmé qu'elle
soit bien programmé et après avoir pas
mal réfléchi je me suis dit qu'on en
fait la meilleure façon je suis puisse
faire ça c'est d'une part qu'on continue
et cette vidéo a essayé de pousser les
gens à réfléchir à ces questions et
d'autre part vu que j'ai pas
l'impression que pan de gens s'y mettent
vraiment laissé en division 1 afin de
maîtriser tous les concepts de l'ia et
puis il faut s'entourer d'une communauté
qui est prêt à paris ça pour pouvoir
passer des années à écrire un article
qui sera peut-être jamais publié du
corps parce que c'est un article
tellement bizarre que personne ne va là
accepter et qui va être rejetée par les
académique classique
voilà c'est super du cygne commence me
bats faut que je fasse moi parce que moi
j'ai rien à perdre la raquette et mythe
est déjà finie congo je serai jamais un
chercheur traître a reconnu du coup l'on
boive à je peux permettre de travailler
sur été ce qui me semble important
plutôt que sur les questions qui feront
avancer ma carrière et du coup j'ai
écrit un truc sur écrit l'article qui je
pense est le plus important aujourd'hui
pour faire avancer la recherche sur un
mois désir et en particulier cet article
qui s'appelle de roadmap for loving
problème c'est un article qui a est
composé de trois parties la première
partie de cet article insiste énormément
sur l'importance de la morale des ira
donc ça parle un peu de ce dont je parle
dans cette vidéo mais de beaucoup plus
d'arguments encore un ça parle aussi du
fait que c'est un problème très
difficile et qu'il faut absolument
d'éviter la recharge dès maintenant et
que en particulier faut arrêter de se
dire que l'humain est la solution pour
stopper une ia dangereuse mais c'est pas
comme ça que ça a marché
un humain est quelqu'un de teint croyab
le mans peu fiables aujourd'hui la
raison en lui la faille de sécurité
première des systèmes de sécurité
notamment en cryptographie cetc
d'humains c'est le nom est exclue
extrêmement dangereux
le principal danger pour une arme
nucléaire pour l'utilisation d'une arme
nucléaire aujourd'hui c'est un humain
qui comprend mal tel ou tel le signal
qui
ou qui prend pas suffisamment nourriture
et qui lançait des armes nucléaires il
faut rendre compte de tout ça s'apprend
partie de l'article la deuxième partie
représente le roadmap en essayant de
découper le problème doit avoir des
acquis un problème incroyablement
difficile et un tremblement contexte qui
a énormément d'étapes nécessaires et
angola roadmap essaie d'identifier les
étapes clés de la résolution de ce
problème et essaie d'identifier des
espèces de son problème d' espèce de
défi pour des différents chercheurs
j'espère que va si vous êtes chercheur
autant aller lire ça et que vous allez
être intéressé par certains des
problèmes que je soulève c'est vrai que
j'ai pas encore réussi à le faire mais
j'aimerais essayer de trouver tourner un
peu tous ces problèmes en soi ont des
défis d'une machine learning soit en des
conjectures mathématiques
même si ça rate on pas exactement au
point mais l'idée c'est d'attirer les
chercheurs veut dire voilà vous fait
vous pouvez des théorèmes et gagner en
légitimité et envoie en popularité et en
grade en pouvant des théorèmes ou en
faisant des trucs difficiles
ouais c'est cool ça sera encore que cool
si vous faites plaisir exactement la
même chose mais les truies que vous
projet lecture que vous prouviez les
démonstrations poule fait ce soit à des
fins utiles notamment d'un point de vue
d'enfants du altruisme efficace en
particulier le truc le plus utile
aujourd'hui je prends soin de travailler
sur ces problèmes que des morales désir
et enfin la troisième partie de cet
article
pour ceux parmi vous qui ne font pas de
recherche ou qui veulent faire en plus
en plus de recherches autre chose
je pense que c'est à part une partie qui
peut beaucoup intéressé beaucoup parmi
vous qui qui correspond un peu guidance
sur un essai de leigh de choses à faire
importante pour que l'amour adevia s'est
passé on puisse être programmée mais ce
sont des défis qui sont vos techniques
servait pas besoin de comprendre
intelligence artificielle une machine
learning pour contribuer à résoudre le
problème de morale désir il ya
énormément de défis intermédiaires qui
sont longs technique
et l'un des plus importants de ces défis
c'est juste apprendre à mieux dialoguer
mieux débattre a dû discuter à mieux
parler de morale surtout éviter de juste
faire des tirades monologues des choses
que tout entendu un milliard de fois
dans sa vie et si on devait avoir des
débats plus intéressant plus plus plus
stimulant intellectuellement qu'ils
fassent davantage réfléchir qui vont
plus loin dans la réflexion qui surtout
nous faut nous remettre en question qui
permettent de mieux cerner les limites
de notre morale intuiti de savoir où est
ce qu elle peut s'appliquer de façon
raisonnable est scanné peut absolument
pas s'appliquer et c'est très important
de savoir où est-ce qu'elle ne
s'applique pas parce que lorsqu on se
dit bon balle à l'entente du moral
clairement je suis incompétent et un
mois + plus je n'ai aucune idée vraiment
un mois plus aucune idée de ce qu'ils
penseraient de ce que je pense moi
aujourd'hui
si on arrive à se dire ça on arrive à se
convaincre que notre intuition morale
présente sur telle question par exemple
n'est pas pertinente et qu'il vaut mieux
déferré son jugement à quelqu'un dont on
voit quelque chose ou quelqu'un dont on
attribue dont on peut faire confiance
aux dépens d'une morale se dit peut-être
que cet individu là sur ces questions
morales sera beaucoup plus proche que
moi plus soudé mois puisse plus que je
ne le suis aujourd'hui
ben c'est ce genre de réflexe que
j'aimerais promouvoir davantage
j'aimerais que quand on se débat
on arrête d'imaginer que c'est un débat
entre mois contre toi mais qu'on essaie
d'imaginer à travers la discussion
comment est ce que le mot mois + + et le
toit puisse plus delgrès et qu'est ce
qui on en sortirait de sorte que à la
fois moi et toi nous nous rapprochions
tous les deux autant que possible de nos
mois + + ou au moins d'un mois plus donc
c'était une vidéo pour vous parler de
l'importance d'un moral de mes
sentiments d'aujourd'hui ah oui un autre
truc que je voulais dire qu'il est
toujours pas fini je suis désolé c'est
que tout ça déchire havrais pas tout
seuls font ça fait deux ans que j'essaie
de voir de vous amener à mieux réfléchir
à ces sujets là mieux parler de morale
et tout ça dès puis inséré sur un fini
en fait d un petit peu soir utilité
j'avais essayé un petit but mais sur un
fini c'était vraiment ça dit dessaisir
va arrêter de tout ramener à la logique
parce que logique c'est pas si logique
et la logique et de super contre
intuitive et si le truc que vous
pourriez être plus fiable
ici le contre intuitif et hier contre
intuitif contre l'intuition
littéralement bas peut-être qu'il faut
arrêter de faire dans ces conditions il
a commencé déjà sur cette partie sur un
fini donc assez assure démocratie j'ai
beaucoup parlé des morales et tout ça et
en cette paris sur lee avait ce soir
sedan c'est parti sur l'ia également ou
en fait l'ia c'est super bien c'est
super intéressant parce que ça combine à
la fois les questions morales et sa
combine aussi des questions de quesques
biographie cher puisque finalement le
sujet de l'ira s'est finalement essayé
de dan et les machines à bien y
réfléchir
et si on comprend comment les machines
peuvent être un bien bien réfléchir
peut-être que nous nous pouvons être
amenés à mieux réfléchir nouvelle ça
fait longtemps que je travaille sur ces
questions que j'essaie d'année vous
amener à mieux réfléchir de m'amener
aussi amusante et cher j'ai énormément
progressé
c'est vraiment moi plus par rapport au
mois déjà 10 à 6 mois et du moins ya
deux ans clairement mais même dieu -
d'irak et quelques mois j'en suis très
content et j'espère continuer à
progresser à avoir approché tour plus du
moins plus plus
mais malheureusement elle a l'impression
qu'ils vont travailler ça ne suffira pas
particulier à chaque fois que j'ai sur
twitter c'est un petit peu déprimé de
voir quel point les débats sont pas tels
que j'aimerais qu'il soit et je pense
que ça vient tout simplement du fait
qu'une personne seule ne suffit pas que
j'en ai parlé dans vidéos précédentes
c'est super important de développer tout
un environnement qui parle de tout ça et
pour avoir tout cet environnement qui
parle de tout ça il faut absolument que
je ne soit plus le seul à parler de ça
faut que je ne sois pas le sol c'est pas
que soit le seuil
je vous fais tu participes - thibault
met ses fiches un ex anglo pour parler
de beaucoup de dpc question également
j'ai le mental est également né un vrai
que plus de gens ce matin à promouvoir
les façons de bien par les plaisirs
normand où sont font que les gens disent
des bêtises
skip serrières disent des bêtises dire
des bêtises sur tous ses signaux betty
sont intelligentes
ainsi si les trucs faux mais voilà pour
des bonnes raisons de dire c'est tout
une bonne chose et c'est très largement
secondaire à mon sens par rapport à
cette quête d'un mois + plus ils
essaient de mieux cerner les intuitions
morale du mois + plus voilà c'était une
longue discussion
il yad'autres plein de choses à rajouter
la jeune fille chose en tête et douleurs
ajouté mais dans ce cas les lieux déjà
assez dingue est telle qu'elle est et je
reviendrai sur d'autres points plus tard
en tout cas j'espère que ça va à nourrir
votre réflexion
du coup je vous invite à à bien y
réfléchir les si vous commentez prenez
bien le temps de réfléchir
quel de deux tournées dans votre tête ce
que vous allez claire demander si c'est
que vous allez faire n'est pas une
banalité une des plus que vous sortez
sans avoir réfléchi je me semble avoir
réfléchi été le cas voile est sans doute
déjà lu dans cette banalité donc ça ça
c'est pas forcément utile de leur dollar
ajouté à nouveau mais si vous avez bien
réfléchir si les plantes question posée
si le clan de réflexion en cours même si
elles sont erronées
jean l'italie mais dans les commentaires
pour qu'on débatte qu'ensemble et comme
débattre mieux les soirs que l'on se
rapproche tous deux nous mois + plus à
l'écart des chroniques avec 1 180
[Applaudissements]